we are so excited for fans to get their
hands on the first DLC of the season
we've been listening to your feedback
and we have so much more to come we've
got four intense maps and a brand new
zombie experience one of the great
things about DLC is it gives us the
first opportunity to address what the
players are looking for and what things
can be improved upon
in the infinite warfare experience we
get a lot of feedback across social
media forums everywhere it's been really
cool to see everything from beta up till
now the requests so you're gonna see
drastic changes and things you love
brought into these new maps
Maur is a dark grimy moody Brooklyn from
the distant future on one side you spawn
under the Brooklyn Bridge which is kind
of gritty and then the exact opposite
side of the map it's a little bit nicer
there's cafes and parks and then in the
middle is just a war zone neon is a
virtual training simulator for urban
warfare
it's a Z shaped map with a long sight
line down the middle a high B point up
on a Ledge in a close-quarters area in a
nightclub on the third Lane when you run
around cars will generate players when
they die they will dissolve into mess of
polygons it's a very interesting and fun
place to be
one of the maps in DLC one that we are
pretty excited about is called
Renaissance it takes place in Venice
it's a very tight quarters very fast
gameplay if you like the snipe you're
gonna love the Church Lane if you like
to run a gun with your shotgun or your
SMG you're gonna love skating through
the interiors engaging players and if
you're a mobile mid Ranger you're gonna
love taking your assault rifle onto the
streets
another map we have is called Dominion
and it's a modern warfare 2 remake of
the classic map Afghan this time it
takes place on Mars Afghan is such a
revered map not just amongst the fans
but also among everybody at infinity
ward it has a lot of different
identifiable landmarks that everybody
can remember the crash ship the AAA guns
on the hill and we knew it was kind of
an easy transition over to infinite
Warfare's theater of war and layers can
out boost jump up to the lookout and
counter snipers with close range
engagements but Raven the Redwoods is a
trip back to the 1990s to a place that
is such a stark contrast from what we
did in zombies in space land I think
players are in for real surprise we made
them really comfortable in space land by
opening up lanes making it bright and
colorful this is really a horror film
brought to life in a video game form
it's going to blow people's minds after
getting sucked out of Tommy's in space
land our four characters appear in a
cabin they wake up kind of groggy they
kind of realize that there may be in the
90s now as you explore outside of the
cabin find out that you're actually in a
abandoned camp that's been kind of taken
over by a few hundred raver kids that
are throwing up an all-night rave party
in the middle of the woods the level has
this dark foreboding kind of spooky vibe
and then the world comes alive
[Music]
there's new weaponry there's new fate
and fortune cards coming new traps
within the map our cast of characters
are getting a whole new wardrobe change
we're gonna introduce a new character
named the slasher there's so much more
to tell
we can't wait for people to get a chance
to experience what it's like to be in
rave in the redwoods people are in for a
real treat
all the devs here at Infinity Ward
cannot wait for our fans to get their
hands on the new cons the weapons the
quests there's so much going into it
fans are going to be super excited Call
of Duty infinite warfare DLC one pack
will be available January 31st first on
ps4 get the season pass and receive $20
of bonus content